here to break down the politics of the
week is gabriel d benedetti national
correspondent for new york magazine he
is in charlottesville virginia
gabe will get to that virtual convention
in a minute but let's start with the
pick of kamala harris as the vice
presidential candidate along with joe
biden
how is this being viewed right now by
the party
well most people in the party are pretty
excited about this there was a lot of
apprehension because of course joe biden
did take quite a long time to make his
choice but
in the end it was in line with
traditional timing just before the
convention harris of course is a
historic pick
as the first black and first asian
american person on a ticket
the first black woman i should say on
the presidential ticket and while she is
a fairly liberal senator
she is pretty much within the center of
the party in many ways so i think a lot
of people were pretty excited to see her
added
one of the things the campaign has
already started focusing on has been the
handling of the coronavirus response
from the trump administration how
effective has that been so far
well if you look at the polling numbers
the biden team and a lot of democrats
would say very effective in the sense
that joe biden does
tend to have a fairly large lead here
but it isn't because he's been doing
all that much work really on that
messaging it's really because
of the president's handling itself this
is the overwhelming crisis that's
everyone is dealing with right now
whether you look at it as a health care
issue or as an economic
issue these all wrap together and of
course when we have tens of millions of
people out of work
uh hundreds of thousands of people dying
and many more sick it's sort of an
inescapable thing and naturally the
election is going to be then viewed as a
referendum on the president
michelle miller here in the democratic
national convention starts albeit
virtually on monday
what do you expect the messaging will
look like
well joe biden's messaging has actually
been fairly consistent from start to
finish when he launched his campaign
he's
always said that this is the battle for
the soul of the nation and
it's not very subtle of course what he's
saying is we have to take the country
back from donald trump
in his words but one thing that we're
going to see is a really wide spectrum
of speakers
you have john kasich who's of course a
former republican governor of ohio who
ran against donald trump speaking on the
same night
as bernie sanders is of course as
progressive as they come so
what the messaging really is going to be
is you don't have to be a liberal you
don't have to be a progressive
to vote for joe biden you have to just
not like what's going on right now
there's going to be a lot of messaging
about
restoration of the soul of the nation in
joe biden's words
yeah messaging on range there it's it's
becoming increasingly clear that
this election will be unlike any other
mail in ballots
and the postal service itself are at the
center of this political debate
so will trump's hardball approach there
uh have political repercussions
uh yeah i mean it's more of an actual
voting issue than a political issue
obviously voters don't like to hear
that their postal service is having
issues because people do really rely on
the postal service
but what a lot of folks are very worried
about is of course because of this
pandemic there's going to be
massive reliance on mainland ballots and
if the postal service is underfunded as
it currently is
it certainly looks like a lot of
people's votes may not be counted or
there might be big
issues with that so there's a lot of
apprehension in the democratic side in
particular and now that president trump
has essentially come out and said
that one of the reasons he's
underfunding the postal service is
because of mail-in ballots uh there's a
real push in the democratic side to make
sure that every ballot
can be safely counted in enough time and
what looks very likely now is we may not
know well it's unlikely that we will
know
the full extent of the vote in a lot of
these swing states on election night so
we should really be preparing
for an election week especially if the
postal service continues to have all
these issues and doesn't get more
funding
okay gabriel b benedetti from new york
magazine thank you very much appreciate
it